في فقره تريد اليوم رصدنا تفاعلا على
منصات التواصل الاجتماعيه مع خطه لشركه
الفيسبوك لتسريحه عدد كبير من موظفيها
وتفاعل مع الوسم المغردون ونشطون واعتبروا
ان الشركه المالكه للفيسبوك ميته تسيره
على خطى شركات العده في مجال التكنولوجيا
اثرت بان شركه متى تخطط فعلا لبدي تسريح
العمال على نطاق واسع هذا الاسبوع ما يؤثر
على الاف الموظفين الرئيس التنفيذي
لفيسبوك مارك زوكربيرج قال انه يتوقع ان
تستغرق الاستثمارات العكسيه قرابه عقد من
الزمان حتى تؤتي ثمارها موضحا انه في غضون
ذلك اضطر الى تجميد التوظيف واغلاق
المشاريع واعاده تنظيم الفرق لخفض
التكاليف فيسبوك خفضت في يونيو حزيران
الماضي خطتها لتوظيف في مهندسين بنسبه 30%
على الاقل
من التفاعلات اسامه بركه من كتب يقول
فيسبوك من يوم ازمه الخصوصيه
وتهرب مارك من الاعتراف بانتهاك الخصوصيه
للمستخدمين اثناء الجلسه الاستجواب
بالكونجرس وهم في مازق كبير والازمه اثيره
من وقتها هذا ما قاله اسامه بركه ورده اخر
عبد الله يقول السبب الرئيسي ان التيك توك
ساره رقم واحد وجذب كل مستخدميه فيسبوك
والانستغرام
وحاليا الانستغرام صار ممل لان اغلب للي
فيه تركوه وراحوا التيك توك انا لم اذهب
للدكتور اسامه
كما قال سامي الربايعه اعتقد التسريح
الحاصل له جانب ايجابي فتسريحهم يعني ان
هناك فرصه للخروج لخروج شركات رياديه اخرى
من بعضهم او باستغلال خبراتهم وتوضيهم في
شركات قائمه او ستقام اما الجانب السلبي
له انه لا توجد وظيفه امنه حتى لو في كبرى
الشركات العالميه سامي الربايعه